hi my name is tanner buchanan hey my
name is stolomaridwenya
and i'm william zapka hi i am mary
mauser hi i'm jacob bertrand
i'm peyton list hi i'm ralph camachio
and we are the cast of netflix's cobra
kai
with buzzfeed to answer all of your
burning questions and obviously
that means there may be some spoilers
everyone has been talking about the love
triangle between sam miguel and robbie
what can you tease about their
relationships in season three
drama in the best way possible in my
opinion that's what i want to watch when
i'm watching a show
i love most of all the budding heads and
then not making it work
even more than when it's actually
working i will say
that no matter what team you're on i
think you get a moment but i also don't
want to spoil anything
teen relationships everything's
complicated probably all over the place
just like real life relationships i mean
you never know which way it's gonna go
perfect tease we've had some good times
some bad times
but in season three i hope to only you
know further develop those relationships
whether that be
with sam you know in a relationship or
just as uh friends or enemies or whereas
miguel and robbie we make
exactly yeah who do you think sam
belongs with
actually uh neither one of these guys i
think i think they're both tennis
they've got a long way to go
they got to figure their stuff out they
have some growing if i was daniel
russo which i'm not but if i was i would
prohibit sam from seeing either one of
them until
until college sam sam belongs with our
overprotective dad
being monitored constantly i love
watching them
watching her in both of those
relationships i think in their best
incarnation i think she's good with
either one of them
i think you're a good influence on both
of the boys
so it's kind of it's kind of hard like i
feel like robbie needs your character
i feel like you're the rock for robbie
but then also you and miguel are so cute
together so
tori would be like she deserves to be
alone
i got a stick up for my boy miguel you
know he was the day one i mean yeah
robbie does need a rock but talk to your
dad bro let miguel
hang out
without your drama in therapy robbie
okay
that's probably true it's like sam's job
to fix you
okay season two ends on a huge
cliffhanger
how early into season three will we find
out if miguel is still alive and if
he'll be able to fight again
the short answer is we'll find out
pretty early into the season whether or
not miguel is alive
and in terms of whether or not he's
going to be able to fight again i think
that's uh
a question that you know we'll have to
wait and find out robbie
screwed up a lot in the in the c in
season two finale
by uh hurting miguel and uh as tanner i
would say that uh
i kind of hope that we find out pretty
soon as well
i know robbie needs a nemesis why do you
want me to be okay
yeah i need to keep fighting cobra kai
originally debuted in 2018 on youtube
premium
and now it's been in netflix's top 10
for weeks
what does that feel like how has the
massive fan reaction to the show
felt i had no concept for how it was
actually going to play out and now it's
pretty wild
people have lots to say in my dms it's
weird
how many people have watched the show
and
it's cool to be a part of it because i
came onto it in the second season
and even later than you guys who are a
part of it from the beginning for me i
just feel really
fortunate it's honestly an amazing thing
it's like the second
rebirth of the first rebirth of the
original franchise
and it just it feels awesome this whole
rollout has been
one kind of surprise and exciting
reveal after the other and when we
debuted on youtube originally it was a
thrill to see
people sign on and watch and we're
counting the numbers going up and up and
up and
uh we're kind of repeating that but on a
massive scale worldwide and
it feels incredible it's it's i think
we're all super excited to see how the
show's connecting with people all over
the world
it's really fun to see just just the fan
base
building on top of what we already had
yeah it definitely feels wonderful to uh
see people uh react to something that
you know we filmed almost two years ago
at this point a lot of people think that
tory and sam could be a dynamic duo
if they became friends what will next
season have in store for them
in their rivalry i don't even know how
to answer that one
i do agree i actually think it could be
a badass duo
they honestly should become friends i
would love for them to become friends at
some point but it's the same thing as
that like
i love the drama yeah i think uh tori
and sam have a
a a long road to uh kinship we love to
see them
at each other's throats and yet we long
for them to get along
they're different but same you know and
uh they have a long way to go for sure
i mean this is fresh moon so maybe 30
years they could be a dynamic
[Laughter]
jacob how long does the mopac and tattoo
application take
the mohawk takes about an hour and the
tattoo it used to take like 45 minutes
because i would dance
well they would try to put it on i
started sitting still and now it takes
like maybe 25 minutes
toward the end of season two johnny and
daniel seem to appreciate each other a
little more
now that crease has taken over cobra kai
will we see
johnny team up with daniel and miyagi
dough
that is the burning question i think
there's always a chance
uh that johnny and daniel could somehow
find a way but they can't get out of
their own way and push themselves aside
to see through
the buttons that each other pushes it's
the joy of watching those characters in
that way
and the frustration and now daniel and
johnny have
small armies behind them that are all
clashing so there's a lot
in the way of the two of them i think
did you guys keep anything from the set
you did you did i i got to keep my whole
outfit from my date with sholo we had so
many multiples of that outfit that when
we went to do the photo shoot at the end
of the season
i was definitely sick and couldn't get
there i ended up
rolling off a plane it was a whole
adventure and i was so sick going home
from the photo shoot that frank
our costume designer was like just don't
even change just take your clothes just
wear that outfit out just go
it wasn't even i wouldn't even really
say it was from set but in the
junkyard episode i just found a gear on
the ground
kept the gear a random gear from the
junkyard will johnny find love up in
season three
tanner you want to take that um i'm just
kidding
i don't know if it'll be with uh my mom
but i'd be interested to see if that
would be be a path
to take just to see if you guys could
get back into things
what were the toughest stunts you had to
film for the show it's interesting i
would have thought it was the
big school fight uh in the last in the
season finale but i think it
might have been the initial fight
because i
had barely any time to prepare for that
first fight i felt
so i just felt i was so nervous honestly
the
end of season fight was the most
difficult for me physically
just having to fight for all of those
seconds straight
and make it look somewhat convincing the
entire time and it's so funny watching
it back i cringe so hard i'm like
everybody looks incredible
and then there's me like missing that
look missing that what am i throwing at
when i'm doing that at the moment though
i was so proud of myself we got done
with that thing i was like you know what
we did it
what do i do the one with you and show
low in the woods
oh yeah yeah when it was freezing cold
i don't even know how your bodies were
even working it was just slippery the
ground was
like kind of muddy he had these really
fast punches that he had to block
and just getting the timing down on
those was really really hard to get down
and also we were just so
so freaking cold johnny and robbie have
also started to reconnect
what will season three have in store for
their father-son relationship and will
the russos get in the way of it
i love our last scene in the in the
parking lot tanner and i talked about
this the whole time we were shooting
because
you know is this exchanged relationship
and he'd walk by and i'd see him with
with daniel and i'm like i'm gonna rope
you into cobra kai and
everything well we finally got to the
end where they you know things seem to
be getting on track
and uh we had this the moment outside of
school before the accident you know
that's the beginning of of where they
can start you know now we have a little
bit of a train wreck at the end of what
happened
that's to me the the biggest hole in
johnny's heart is trying to get to
his son i agree with that too because i
believe that scene in the car i believe
that's only how like the second or third
time like i actually call you
dad in the series we've both kind of
been
down and out i mean i was mixed in with
the wrong crowd you know
johnny's been off you know he was
drinking and all kinds of stuff but we
both
really tried to uh turn our lives around
and make something out of ourselves it's
a fun journey and and it's also
the reason why we care we care for those
father-son relationships which were
ingrained in the theme of the original
karate kid as much as it is
can we expect to see any more karate kid
cast cameos
i've played the fifth that's all i'm
gonna say i think people will be happy
but not necessarily in the ways that
they expect
we know a lot about johnny and daniel's
backstage now and we saw a little bit of
pops during season two
will we get to learn anything new about
the characters during season three
i know that for sam we do get some
insight
into her past and you know some
questions that i had about her past
we get a little peek at that which i was
really really appreciative of story-wise
i feel like when tory re-emerges into
season three
you do get to see some backstory i
learned a lot about the character too
which was really cool
finally are you yourselves team cobra
kai
or miyagido i know everyone's answers
mary you are
ten thousand percent miyagido yeah
peyton
you are cobra kai as as am i yeah yeah
like if i were just a student at west
valley high and i saw the cobras like
taking over the school i'd be like
yes i want to be that person that's so
sick
and then i would walk into cobra kai and
immediately be like yeah this is not for
me thanks
and then i would go find myself beyond
you know i mean what's funny is i feel
like
my like aesthetic and my lifestyle is
all very like hardcore badass
cobra kai type of person until you speak
to me and the second half of my mouth
miyagido all over because i knew jacob
before and that was basically the only
person i knew
i mean when he talked about cobra kai he
genuinely seemed like he was a part of
cobra kai i was a little concerned
he really deeply cares about cobra kai
i've never seen someone so
into it no but then as the season went
on second season i started filming i
started getting like oh yeah screw the
miyagi does
uh ralph and william what's it like to
have a totally new generation of fans
who didn't grow up with the karate kid
but are now obsessed with cobra kai
that's
some of the sweetest part of this all
the young generation is now
backing itself into the original films
where they'll see the show
they'll get invested in the show they
get invested in these characters and
then they
go back to watch the original movies you
know what we initially did
back in 1980 wherever it was
to see that you know reinvent itself
with every generation
you know it's beyond i totally agree
with that it feels like the karate kid
came out all over again